the Bavarian town of pale is usually a
sleepy place well that's all changed
since the start of the football World
Cup here at the Town Hall
reporters turn up daily the mayor says
all of them want to know more about
pails most famous inhabitant after
thomas had scored about three goals
media interest increased massively he's
a very interesting person because he's
so natural and authentic here in the
village we've taken it all in our stride
of course were pleased but we're pretty
relaxed about the whole thing
Denis Mesaba relatively keen residents
are extremely proud of their Tomas the
local bakery has a special attraction in
its window display a pair of Mona's old
football boots donated by his family as
a child Munna often came here to buy
sweets a gun sir he was a lively cheeky
boy and funny just like he is now he had
a good sense of humor but it was Nona's
talent that really stood out he learned
to play football on this field and
joined by an Munich's junior team at the
age of just ten since then he's come a
long way here he's seen training with
the national team in Brazil the people
of pails say his phenomenal success is
well-deserved
he's got great instincts and he uses
them that's a rare quality most players
are pushed into a routine Tomas doesn't
allow that and that's a good thing it's
not just Miller sporting prowess that
makes him popular the small-town boy
hasn't let his success go to his head
though he's earned a fortune
people here say his feet remain firmly
on the ground there he speaks and
behaves just like us he doesn't act like
a Ronaldo Rebecca round here he's just
one of the lads
so he's in for her push films
the World Cup final against Argentina
will be doubly exciting for the
residents of pale because of their
personal connection with Miller Thomas
reloaded I'm some - I say Thomas Miller
is going to shoot two goals for Germany
on Sunday and I'm seldom wrong if
Germany do become the World Cup
champions the quiet village of pale in
upper bavaria is likely to get a little
louder for a while